okay [ __ ] it's your [ __ ] boy
psychobabble I don't really got [ __ ] to
Saturday and then though actually I got
a lot of [ __ ] to say today okay I got a
lot of [ __ ] on my nerves
first off I'm going to dinner I don't
know what time so I don't know how I'm
going to cut this looks like second all
this let's play maybe one of the worst
Let's Plays I've ever done because and
if there's taxi and I you know
psychobabble just hates reading like
reading is hard like rusty there's new
words every day you know what's wrong
with pictures pictures don't change so
you know
second of all okay I just spent like six
hours on the flux of options menu trying
to figure out where subtitles are so
okay I love Luke okay let me just show
you what I'm doing with here you got an
option right okay you only got a couple
of choices graphics control sound
gameplay language now my first go-to for
[ __ ] subtitles a sound and sure
enough there's nothing about [ __ ]
like subtitles so I'm like okay I can
you know it's probably a graphic so I
got a graphics like that's probably here
you know like okay a lot of stuff here
they have like everything bloom basing
all sorts of stuff but you know they
just don't kind of sucked kind of okay
and then I checked like okay maybe it's
a game play like you they throw it in
there sometimes and looking and looking
like there's no [ __ ] sense I guess
there's nothing this game but you know I
might as well like check another spot
and touching language is the woman oh
whatever it uses and sure enough here it
is so I'm just tired of that you know
that's one thing that makes life
difficult at times you can use this -
let me get a little comfy okay okay okay
let's do this great yes what we in the
[ __ ] 41 what is this the next type is
what if this whole thing was just a
giant koi for the developers that make
you a secure mixtape Fulbright company
oh [ __ ] that I didn't apply to be it do
be an employee this is the w-2
hi mom so I got my ticket home from
Europe I get back on June 6 but it's a
really late flight because that was the
cheapest so it gets in at midnight but
don't worry I'll get a shuttle from the
airport so you don't have to pick me up
like really seriously you don't have to
ok so love you see you soon bye
she sounds hot damn it just be hot ok so
I'm going home going home or no past
tense
I've gone home 1995 I 1:15 a.m. all is
shut [ __ ] I'm late
ok oh [ __ ] ok well [ __ ] the cursor
thing is way too [ __ ] fat holy [ __ ]
control not sensitivity [ __ ] an egg
what is that rewind
okay just kind of [ __ ] fast geez dad
what's up look okay this is much better
okay rainy out there sure I'm glad I'm
at out there that's suck to be like a
raccoon or something okay what is this
I'm Caitlin Greenbrier from Berlin was
up today's date okay God plants got
anything over here
anything over here open door [ __ ]
lights grab the Christmas done say
there's a [ __ ] key right there we
have second key come on duck and come
with me
wait what the [ __ ] is this can I throw
it yeah
come on doctor come with me Oh what is
this a painting that's me I'm sorry I
can't be to see you but it's impossible
please please don't go digging around
try to find out where I am
okay no probs go sleep I don't want
anyone to know we'll see each other
again someday don't be worried I love
you okay come on George Smith duck is a
[ __ ] again but that I [ __ ] missed
the memo
what's that static now
no directions to work from new house 10
minutes I don't give a [ __ ]
workers for poor people clothes sure
we'll add this one in here hey Shannon
there you hear anything okay [ __ ] me
then Jenice what is this [ __ ] spam oh
my text message it says from Fred whole
show so it's it from hell
[ __ ] a the smell sensitivity is way
too [ __ ] loud
put it back no [ __ ] wood
what Duff [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ]
was that is that goes on the board game
over the Alps
okay [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is it sound to the rain anything in here
now at Deer Chan for Janice or let's say
Sam I think Jan kept hearing from Yaga
the house business so blob too much to
read pick up my old tractor Oh fate
[ __ ] locked so typical
come on done right now Sam Daniel for
the old neighborhood call he wants to
see the new house called back mom Daniel
weirdo the only reason I ever hung out
with him in the first place
created $10 a little okay [ __ ]
lightning please be there
hi mom so I got my ticket home from
Europe I get back on June 6 but it's a
really late flight because that was a
decent okay but don't worry I'll get a
shuttle from the airport so you don't
have to pick yeah that's really
piercings oh okay so love you Suzanne
bye
[Music]
[ __ ] weird
okay this is [ __ ] weird said Katie oh
that's right
janitor [ __ ]
it's like TV plan or something
okay that's none of my business they
said oh my god
you are so lucky finished high school
before we moved into this house so it's
the first day of school and there I am
introducing myself to the class and I
say that I just moved into the house on
Arbor Hill all of a sudden every kid in
the room turns and just stares like
she's suddenly transformed into a mutant
they just stood there pushing pretty
hard for a rewind button because now
maybe nobody knows my name but they all
know who I am that psycho house girl
great what's the sake of house I guess
I'll find out hey sir know that yeah I
don't need any of that devil me as I get
here okay okay okay
today's s Utley Santa [ __ ] Sam thought
this might help
making friends you know that feeling
where the first moment you see someone
it's like they have a big gold star
around them and you have to get to know
them well there's this girl I think
she's a senior she's usually dressed
kind of punk but sometimes I see her in
this like army uniform she's always
drawing in this notebook looking at 2.10
I had no idea how I would ever like have
an excuse to talk to her till I noticed
she and her friends hang out and play
Street Fighter at the 7-eleven every day
after school
okay residents are strongly urged what
is this a plus [ __ ] a check I can't
tell if this has got a Hargett or not so
I'm just praying it tonight because I'm
not really good with power games and I
like a but what is this the x-files of
25 hello have people outside okay at
dirt a challenger here
okay I'll change the channel change here
it's got to be right here somewhere all
right
just do the kit covers the [ __ ] the
channel changer what kind of house is
this
how's that you get up
okay well enough of that hey are you the
new girl Sam that time it just thought
you're new maybe you could use a friend
I don't have a lot of friends I thought
I'd ask if you don't mind do you mind
now was it just your uncle who went
psycho does it run in the family
alright guy so [ __ ] darkish [ __ ] in
here oh hell no I'm taking this one tour
at a table just in case this [ __ ] gets a
little crazy electrical check up the
safety now thank you no thank you
alright [ __ ] here what is up there
[ __ ] a this thing is like this thing
is making me [ __ ] dizzy
yes now thank you
you can do better
yeah what's the combination
the hell is that and else here like
creaking
Sara
what is that the exit Oh pariah and a
keg
[Music]
career path no thank you
- [ __ ] is this so say [ __ ] book town
I don't know why
okay the father [ __ ] writes books but
the [ __ ] was canceled caring please give
this to your mother
okay when you live in one place your
whole life your next-door neighbor is
kind of like your default friend and
Daniel only got weirder over the years
living away has been a good excuse to
like not see him anymore but he did
always have the good Nintendo game maybe
I'll give him a call the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] that's missing
whatever you fail don't tell mama dad
the Attic [ __ ] is this do you know what
they say about the best laid plans of
mice and men I don't know yeah turns out
it applies to Street Fighter 2 at least
I worked up the courage to walk into the
7-eleven and ask for a turn but all that
practice at home did not exactly
translate in the wild so after I was
finished getting my butt kicked
I followed them outside while they
smoked and that was when she asked me if
I was that psycho house girl but then
she said she's always really wanted to
see the psycho house her name is Loni
she's coming over tomorrow
smoke detector up there yeah personnel
trader um trying real hard not to get
this egg the [ __ ] second chef
it's weird hanging out with girl daniel
was around ever since I was little and
other girls
I don't know but being around Lani is
like instantly just right I gave her the
grand psycho house tour and took my
revenge on Super Nintendo it was like I
don't know I finally found someone I
feel normal
around Lani brought her hair dye over
today she said I need to fix these roots
then he could help dyeing hair is
weirdly intimate you know if I've
touched someone else's out before
that's pretty intimate right it's felt
intimate we looked in the mirror
together after and I expected her to say
something about how it looked crappy or
good or whatever but that's when she
said you're so beautiful
and she was looking at me right in that
moment I wanted to say something I
waited
and the moment was gone [ __ ] gets like
scary once the [ __ ] audio goes back
okay oh this should be the culmination
right I get a [ __ ] headache
holy [ __ ] that is horrifying
[Music]
now I'd double using that's going on
over here just a trap
[ __ ] this
[Applause]
[ __ ] I'm just turning all the [ __ ]
lights in the hot so I'm going to [ __ ] I
know what else [ __ ] hear that
like that we're going to make up the
guest room free to stay I will be
needing it anymore what the [ __ ] man
that is cue me the [ __ ] creeps
okay so what is that
all right I guess we're going to do what
we're not supposed to do no thank you
I don't read garbage chute dad how the
[ __ ] do I get in man she's [ __ ] down
an ice and shake another way in
this is Sam's room now this is the guest
room that's not made so this is Sam's
room there's going to be a button all
right
[ __ ] where is that sometimes you just
have to lie to mom and dad like when
Lonnie asked me to see a band with her
and stay over to friend's place in the
city after that's a lie to mom and dad
situation but it was so worth it the
girls on stage were just so loud and
real and awesome and everybody was
moving together like one huge tide of
sound between two songs
Lonnie leaned over and said how do you
like your first show I was so happy I
felt here starting in my eyes and then
she up and hugged me I think she could
tell their way to get in there I'm
trying to look at the ceiling
just [ __ ]
so is that at okay we're going to share
because I'm sick of the [ __ ] dog
motion sickness oh that's [ __ ] scary
thanks for watching matches